okay always glad to have such good
opposition here yeah and welcome to this
video first this is Grand Master dr.
John none let's see going to play me
nine here and okay I know I'm probably
okay it's not going for four main lines
I wanted to play my Chi going again I
know I know the problems with this line
but it was curious how he would have
handled that he is actually a pretty
famous game in the in the chi Goran with
my my line against Nigel short from the
early 80s I think or even late seventies
one of the earliest games on that Nigel
short plate when he was still a teenager
I maybe I could have chicken before
actually hmm okay okay if I take T form
he has to take with the bishop right and
then c5 isn't this a good position if he
doesn't take with the bishop I'm just
winning the pawn right and then nc5 that
should be quite good
so he's basically saying that Knight
takes e4 is not so great or what and
take everything it takes this example
came I see I seem but it's difficult for
me not to do that one now that I have
opted for the whole thing so we takes
them queen is seven maybe I have to get
rid of this pin we wait wait wait chip
chick c5 might even be a move okay how
to play here
ruki six queen d 5 is not helping me
doesn't help him doesn't have a night if
I fo is offering a pawn sacrifice I had
certain moments maybe interesting
actually interesting 93 yards and took
me ages to see that 93 and nights you
form should have played that much
quicker Queen DEA drug the aid Bishop c5
I can take e 1 and half and i also have
night see form entered it's quite
interesting
oh that is sneeze there Wow fortune
fortunately I could suppress microphone
at the right moment so you your ears
didn't didn't fall off him okay so what
is he thinking about all right exactly
okay so what is he thinking about did
not I did not mean to imply that it is
simple or anything just did I was just
curious like what is he thinking about
so um I can take now take f3 hmm
interesting
I wonder if I can let's do it like that
I should have chicken you fight first
I'll check but ok check I have an idea
concrete one like this taking the pawn
add on a three I go before it's
interesting
III before okay it's enough for equality
I guess check yeah i mean i can i can i
don't know if i can can I give a way of
seven I don't know
so that was the idea
otherwise my rook would be in a quite
funny situation down here for it doesn't
have many useful return squares and this
makes sense of my bishop so what is this
actually equal or do I have grounds some
grounds to hope for more I'm taking
check and March the a pawn my point is
nice I can start with a 5 ride maybe
takes rook cheeks ok I'm starting to
capture here check if it's probably
still quite draw much check
so
time warning yeah a quickie he be
threatens to watch this now
well I underestimated that
quite a lot actually are stupid
ok
54 maybe and then Roxy one maybe it's
still okay Jack I know now this this is
the problem so shoot Bishop Bishop
deform I screwed that up wow wow that
was difficult to do black resins mean I
could draw it will yeah I just wanted to
win this that was stupid okay here
drawing is very easy i can play whatever
they are because it can never take on
before just on repeat you i mean drawing
is very easy i just wanted to win the
game but then in the process I lost it I
mean just 44 draw I can do this for
example which way to betrayed everything
here mmm stupid sorry bad young it's
probably a draw for quite a bit still
but yeah the problem is i can never go
to see what I can really never go with
them so here it gets very critical
already and he had lost him that was
very bad check okay it was very jackal
to lose that game so yeah what I can do
this this is mrs. maybe a good way to
start just start limiting this Bishop a
little bit and giving myself more more
breathing room look here now ok it's
it's just a drawn nothing more I can
probably don't probably I'm not able to
get more than then those pawns traded
the only way to lose was to to play like
like I did basically quite quite bad
okay well thanks for watching